Bill Belichick is 72 years old.
His girlfriend is 24 years old.
That's a 48 year age difference.
This man lived several whole fucking lifetimes
before she was even born.
What do his male friends say?
Well, they just joked about it in the Tom Brady roast.
Gronkowski equipped coach,
you used to talk about Foxboro High School when we sucked,
but now I know why you were so obsessed with Foxboro High School.
Brady later joined in on the jokes,
adding, when somebody asked me which ring was my favorite,
I used to say the next one.
He said, now that I'm retired,
my favorite is that ring.
Camera, that cock.
Coach Bella, Check.
Slinking out of that poor girl's house at 6:00am.
And that's why most men will say
they don't know any man that has ever harmed a woman.
They don't know any man that has ever done anything.
Because even when they see it in their fucking face,
what do they do?
Sanitize it, make jokes about it, and make everything just, oh, yuck,
yuck, yuck.
So even the men who say, not all men,
it's because they're overlooking
what their own fucking closest friends are doing.
They're making jokes about it,
making light about it, as if it's not disgusting as fuck.
Shame on you, Brady!
Shame on you, grandkowski!
Shame on you, fucking Bill Belichick
and everybody else who defends this disgusting fucking behavior!